I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense what made you come to New York
very simple my chef my mentor and and I
don't know how he was in your world
coming up but you have your chef you
have your mentor and that person is
everything for you like there is because
it's not like college like our paths
it's not like you go to college it's not
like you go here you hurt here either
made it or you did that's totally right
it's very subjective yes so when this
person which I really admired and he was
very pivotal and helpful to me in many
ways he just said to me listen you what
you gotta go with me to nice to southern
part of France we opening a place and
that's a chef I can't it's like I gotta
go I gotta go home and I got a do my own
thing and I want to eventually open my
own restaurant and I'm 23 at the time
and he said what are you talking about
you're coming with me and that's what
we're doing what stations like actually
I've pushed back it's like I was really
nervous about this took it back to push
back and and I was nervous about you
don't say no to this person that's the
first time that you push back maybe as I
started to see that I at this point I
felt did I graduate it and this is like
seven years all started to grow some
confidence yeah yeah and then he just
tend to apply a very point-blank
you see Frank he was like listen as a
black man no one it's gonna there is no
market for a black press owned
restaurant with your ambition it doesn't
exist in France it doesn't exist in
Europe it doesn't exist in the world so
I'm I'm just letting you know this is
not gonna happen
gosh see to me I hear that and I think
that's why it's gonna happen yeah I
didn't I wish you were with me in 1994
at that place because that would have
needed use what makes you different is
what makes you stand out you'll never be
like someone else so you have to stand
you have to find a way to stand out I'm
like totally living proof of that so
okay so that word a completely
absolutely you are you got to do the job
yeah
which you know but we did but so then
what did you do
I called my dad and he said just come
home and we'll deal with it when you
come home back to Sweden yeah back to
Sweden and not like he had a plan but he
would take me two days whatever to get
home and they said when I came home
pretty much said you going to New York
do you know anyone in New York I said
yeah I know this one guys like you going
to New York and it's like it's like why
it's like here's the reason why and it's
typical my dad like logic in logic
whatever they're they chose a black
mayor in New York and if they if New
Yorkers could choose a black mayor that
one day will support a black on
restaurant that's it figure it out after
that that's it that was the only piece
go did you believe him I did I mean you
got a hold on like I mean you created a
space that wasn't there right yeah well
I believed for no good reason like when
I was I came back from England you said
I lived in England for three years I
came back I left halfway through his
season came home didn't have a ride that
year the rest of the year didn't have a
ride almost the whole of the year after
that I was 19 and 20 years old like I'm
supposed to be making it to the bigs but
you know like transitioning and I've had
no job but for some reason I really
really believed it was all gonna work
that's it
[Music]